Jim whatever I do I do it to protect you  see understand I understand  there we go our rebellion is all that  remains to push back the Empire  I think he might be able to help us when  was the last time you were in contact  with your father  it appears he is critical to the  development of a super weapon  if my father built this thing we need to  find him all right how many do I need  they are requesting a call sign  it's a rogue road 1 we are dealing with  here  immeasurable  if the Empire has this kind of power  what chance do we have  we have hope rebellions are built on  hope  no idea we're coming  and code of this moment the force is  strong  make 10 men feel like a hundred  take the next chance  dream  you